there you are look at billy how are you
you look like a [ __ ] pride
i stupid headphones to work here some
that'll work let me see if these ones
will work hold on a second no they work
good
my headphones aren't working for me
though oh okay
it's about me nick it's not about you
here here we go
my favorite position is uh doggy style
you're so nasty i no i can't i just
can't deal with the intimacy you know
i don't know who i am as a person yet
and when somebody looks at me
during that time i just i feel like it's
it's i'm exposing too much
i was talking about your position on the
basketball court
i'm just gonna tell you how i discovered
you
i you know i i do owe my whole career to
you yeah
i was i don't know i was struggling
until no no no obviously
covered not discover you in terms of
like
you did it on your own obviously but no
in terms of
my awareness of you oh can i tell you
that story
i remember it was a big day in my career
bobby lee is finally aware of me
am i on bobby lee's radar see this is
what he's got this
is when things start to happen i'm not
going to allow this to that reversal i'm
not yeah i'm not gonna allow this to
happen very soon yeah yeah
i'm just gonna plug away you know what i
mean listen you can talk to him all you
want
i can hear it
did you see my adam sandler interview
kevin neela dude
people told me that you fanned out so
bad this is how much i
love you this is how much i love burke
kreitzer when you when you were like
this
hang on a second hang on adam hang on a
second i have a story
i have a story i want to tell if you
could have a superpower what would it be
uh that's a good one you know what it
would be
when i'm when i'm second in line to make
a left
and the person doesn't pull up to get
out in the intersection and make sure i
make it my superpower would be that i
could mentally
move them out into the intersection
and if they gave me the finger i would
slowly slide them into oncoming traffic
i wouldn't i wouldn't make them hit
because that's an innocent person over
there
man you're the first villain i had on my
show everybody on super power is like uh
marvel characters your [ __ ] is like a
villain they're lying to you
everybody's pretending that they care
they don't if you really listen to
people what they care about is what
affects them
true nobody gives a [ __ ] about the
eight-year-old who made this jacket do i
do i write him and say thank you for
sewing this together
no you know there wasn't internet porn i
got to have a childhood
can you imagine if that [ __ ] was around
when i was oh my god i can't
like these kids nowadays it's like
they're eight years old and the brain
damage they have it's like they've been
on the vice squad for like 40 years
you're not good but like the two
interviews are h3h3 and theo vaughn
where everyone's like did you see that
interview and by the way
knowing you i don't see anything wrong
with the interview i had a great time on
the theo vaughn thing i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened with that
i don't know we had a good time i'd
showed him my truck we had a great
[ __ ] time i thought you guys had a
great time i thought it was a great
interview i think it is
i knowing both of you you were not not
you and he was not not him
people like to take a little [ __ ]
thing and then
gas it up and make it something else and
then it becomes like you know
that's all they're doing that's like
what's funny is the average douchebag
on these [ __ ] social media is no
different
than these giant corporate news agencies
where they're just they're just
taking [ __ ] out of context to cause you
to cause
something that didn't even happen so
you'll stop and watch it
so they can make money off of views yeah
and and people
on the internet do the exact same thing
they know exactly where to cut it
where to begin it and where to end it to
make it to take it from a level two
up to [ __ ] 12. i watched you and
theo's whole interview
didn't find anything wrong with it
including what what people will say is
how it ended which is you going i have
to go i have to leave now yeah
my kid was getting up it had nothing to
do with him and and but when
then i watched the uh uh you you got to
see this interview with bill and theo
and they chop
it up to make it look like you don't
like him you don't get him and
they do that with rogan where they'll
they'll do like his reaction that guy
right
and they can they totally make a
completely different interview that
didn't even happen
oh yeah don't you have to tell me about
that i'm just [ __ ] about all my
yeah so why why would you watch that
[ __ ] i don't i don't i watch it i watch
it but i don't know you but
that doesn't you know [ __ ] you bert
they're gonna cut this up now
it's funny because like even i i
have to admit like i i've discovered a
couple of comics that i love
that are that could be you know
republicans or whatnot
right they're not out but like you hear
rumors and my initial responses what is
wrong with that
i i know i'm just there's nothing wrong
with that they're not out
yeah they're not out as republican no
you know they did they keep their stuff
private is what i meant yeah because
liberals are out of their [ __ ]
i understand that i understand that
listen to my [ __ ] point though okay
let me finish my point
okay my initial reaction is like uh
right but it's like no it's i'm just
gonna make up a name it's joey he's a
good guy
you know it's like you know it's like it
has nothing to do with we're
in it
just love how judgmental the left is you
don't know anything about
he's a good guy he's he is still i
understand for you to get in the comedy
store back in the days
well mitzi didn't pass me i remember
that and sure
everybody has a [ __ ] bad story about
it well she didn't even wait
to the end of my set like i was i was
still up there
this paulie's mom yeah and evidently
like halfway through my set she was just
like he's not
ready wow he just [ __ ] walked out
yeah and i took it personally i was like
man
[ __ ] her [ __ ] this [ __ ] club [ __ ] la
i was like i was like everything west of
the mississippi [ __ ] them they're not
funny
hey dude it's it's like messing with my
whole i had this big discussion with my
wife last night talking about
the irresponsibility of religion
with with a higher power
where they go like oh people have
freedom of choice
so it's just like so when a serial
killer is born
that's not on god at all
like whoa leaned a little too far this
way like that's not on him at all
he gets to walk away from all of that
and if you watch
like all of these nature videos
and just how the whole thing is set up
that you know the big eat the little
and and how there's certain animals that
their only way of survival like rabbits
no [ __ ] defense whatsoever their only
defense that they get is that they can
[ __ ] so much and have
so many of them that you can't wipe them
out but the second you're a rabbit
you know i'm gonna get killed by a snake
eaten by a coyote
ripped apart by wild dogs that is their
[ __ ] existence
and they don't hurt anybody their sex
must be so frantic
and anxious and fueled by i'm finished
the snake's gonna come in here
[ __ ] walked into the singles bob what
did women always say
what do you do they're not making small
talk
okay women all [ __ ] judge
okay their status and then they get a
number in their head
all right and then they find out the
jobs
okay that earn this and earn that and
then they figure like who they can [ __ ]
okay and then it becomes a thing of like
okay
you're underneath what i want for the
lifestyle
that i'm looking for in the future but
you're a good looking enough guy
that i'll [ __ ] bang it tonight maybe
i'll have a little fling with you but
that's at the end of the [ __ ] day
you know when you slid that piece of
paper across the table you made your
offer say my dick and balls bring home
this
each year they're like yeah keep it
moving
keep it moving that's that's 10 grand
less than i want and you got that one
snaggletooth [ __ ] off
move on who's next go ahead put your
junk on the table what's your number
[Music]
you